we're going to start with worries over
the banking system and the massive
efforts now to boost confidence in the
latest effort california-based First
Republic Bank was given a 30 billion
dollar Lifeline from 11 other banks in a
deal partly brokered by treasury
secretary Janet Yellen who also took
questions from Senators on Capitol Hill
yesterday and Capitol Hill is where we
find our Scott McFarland who's covering
all this for us Scott Good morning Tony
good morning to you the nation's
treasury secretary gave temporary
reassurance to lawmakers here about the
state of the U.S banking system but the
big question is what happens next if
another financial institution runs into
trouble
First Republic Bank of California
becomes the third U.S Bank this week to
be rescued from collapse
11 of America's largest financial
institutions agreed to pump 30 billion
dollars into First Republic to stabilize
the troubled lender after its value
tumbled Thursday during early Trading
rattling markets and the bank's
customers I was definitely concerned
with the financial situation you know
after the two Banks went under treasury
secretary Janet Yellen announced the
deal hours after trying to reassure
Congress about the health of America's
banking system I can reassure the
members of the committee that our
banking system is sound and that
Americans can feel confident that their
deposits will be there when they need
them the tumultuous weak for banks has
triggered new debate over a move by then
president Trump and Republicans joined
by 17 Democrats to loosen Bank
regulations in 2018. I think it's
important we pay close attention to
what's happening I think it's important
that this body quit listening to banking
lobbyists but Republicans who supported
the changes five years ago blamed Biden
Administration Regulators for failing to
detect and stop Banks from taking
dangerous risks this Administration has
a great deal of responsibility for the
bank failures that we had as Wall Street
prepares for its final trading this week
There's a sense of uncertainty and if
you just look at the news you can tell
that I think there's a lot more we don't
know than we do know right and so we get
the sense that there will be further
problems
Senators also pressed the treasury
secretary about whether other Banks
Across America would get similar rescues
to the ones issued this week she said
only if there is systemic risk to the
U.S economy
[Music]
Scott thank you